well as I said I consider myself a
pragmatic progressive because I would be
in favor of significantly more public
spending on education for example in the
United States but the pragmatic
adjective means I think we have to be
smart about how we do that there are
cases where we spend a lot of money and
we don't get much results so I think we
need to look at what would actually lead
to better educational outcomes you know
in inner cities for example and
different kinds of communities in the US
but I would be in favor of spending a
lot more money on education I would be
in favor of some kind of national health
system I know this is controversial and
I'm not the best expert to design the
details but I do think the United States
can learn from other countries that have
more successful systems that provide
health insurance to more or less the
whole population so I think there are
things you can do with health and
education that would cushion a lot of
families from some of the shocks that
come with globalization i'm also a fan
of progressive taxation i frankly I
can't get into the specifics of us tax
policy as you know as a world bank
official it's not really my role but I
feel comfortable saying that I believe
in progressive taxation I think if a
country has you know very good
institutions you know good institutions
of property rights and good education
system I think you can have progressive
taxation and you don't have to worry
that all your rich people are going to
leave because your country is actually a
very nice productive place to operate
you know so I think if the if the US
continues to strengthen its basic
institutions I don't think a lot of
people will leave if tax rates go up
modestly so I would be in favor of using
the these are your basic fiscal tools
you know how do you raise tax revenue
and then what public goods do you spend
it on I think we can do a lot I think
any rich country can do a lot to make
people's lives better and cushion some
of the shocks of globalization and I'm
completely in favor of that some of my
critics you know caricature me as being
something of a neoliberal and I
completely reject that I think the the
free trade I
dia is a classic liberal idea and I
associated with progressives going back
a long way so I don't see how cutting
off your economy from the rest of the
world is a progressive idea when from
the point of view of the u.s. most of
the rest of the world is poor they want
to trade with the u.s. they want to come
to the u.s. you know they want
investment from the US I don't see how
cutting the us off from the poor world
is anywhere is in any way of progressive
agenda